في التطورات ايضا ذكرت وكاله رويترز ان
بريطانيا تدرس تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابه لاول
مره لمواجهه القوات الروسيه
العميد الياس حنا ابدا من هذا الخبر الذي
اوردناه قبل قليل وهو ااه بريطانيا تدرس
تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات بتقييمك هل يمكن ان يغير هذا شيء
على ارضك
جلال بالطبع لانه الدبابه هي قوه صدم
لديها مدفع مهم جدا 105 ملم ايضا ان
بريطانيا هي التي اعطت ال ال نسخه الثانيه
من الهايمرز وكانت الاكثر مساعده خاصه في
المجال الاستعلامي الدبابه مع ما قد يخطط
له يعني
المسطحات همم الامريكيه والمصفحات
الالمانيه همم قد تساعد في المرحله
القادمه على تكوين قوه هجوميه خاصه ان
المرحله القادمه يقال ان هي مرحله الهجوم
والهجوم المعاكس بهذه القوات الروسيه
والاكرانيه لماذا تكتسب سوليدار هذه
الاهميه بالنسبه للطرفين في هذه المرحله
المرحله بخموط هي الاساس مع ان بخموت يعني
لم تعد ذات الاهميه الاستراتيجيه يستنزف
فيها نخبه فكنر وغيرها لهدف استراتيجي
قليل الاهميه اللهم اني اذا كان بسبب
الثروات المتواجده فيها سوليدر الهدف
الاخير هو تطبيق محمود من كل الاماكن
سوليدار هي مرحله احكام الطوق حول محمود
وقطعها عن الخلفيه بكلمه تورسكو
واسلوبيانس وقطع اللوجستيه وبذلك تسقط مع
الوقت كما حصل في ماريو بول ما الذي يجب
رصه في هذه المرحله المقبله مع طبعا دخول
فصل الشتاء وتبدل على ما يبدوا وضع في
الجبهات لمصلحه الجيش الروسي
الاستعداد الاوكراني بالمرحله العسكريه
دبابات مضاد للطائرات وبالتالي الاهم جلال
انا اعتقد انه بدانا نرى شيء يحضر في
بيلاروسيا هناك مدينه اصبح فيها ما يقارب
1600 جندي تبعد تقريبا 100 كيلومتر عن
جمال التي كانت
النقطه التي انطلقت منها الهجوم في
المرحله الاولى من الحرب صحيح وبالتالي
بعيده تقريبا 130 كلم عن كياب هذه المرحله
يجب هل سيتكون هناك قوه كامله متكامله مع
بعضها البعض كومباين كما يقال همم للهجوم
على شمال اوكرانيا وقطع طرق المواصلات مع
بولندا هذا هو الامر المهم المرحله
الثانيه هو ماذا سيجري ميليتو بول زدجا
وكيف همم ينتج بخموت هذه الامور تتعلق
بالتحضير العسكري بالالات بالعتاب وكيف
سيكون هناك المخزون الروسي من المسيرات من
السلاح والانتاج وهذه الامور عميد حنا في
بيروت شكرا لك